Britney Spears and boyfriend Sam asghari  pack on the PDA with her kids in tow  oh god I think we nervous think about it  pop star stepped out with her favorite  guys Wednesday night she attended a  Lakers versus Warriors game at the  Staples Center with her beau and sons  Shaun and Jaden it's a lot of fun every  time I do it I'm just like it's fun for  me during the family outing Britney  showed off a lot of skin sporting major  cleavage and high-waisted shorts to  watch the NBA game courtside at one  point the action turned to the stands  catching Britney and Sam sharing a sweet  smooch on the front row and Britt's son  seemed unfazed by the PDA my life is  kind of like a open book before the  basketball game the singer shared a snap  of her home decked out in Christmas  decor this year will be one of the  couple's first holidays together just  gonna be really special really big  you  [Music]